hello everybody uh my name is Michael
fee uh it's my honor uh to introduce our
speaker today uh who will give the third
annual Philip a sharp lecture in neural
circuits uh this lecture series was
sponsored by Biogen IC to honor the
contributions of Phil sharp who's with
us today uh one of these was his role in
helping to found Biogen IC um a leading
biotech company as well as his uh
contributions here at MIT he was
chairman of the biology Department uh as
well as um uh director of mit's cancer
uh Center for Cancer Research In
addition Phil uh was the founding
director of the McGovern Institute for
brain
research so it's also my honor uh and
privilege to host our speaker today uh
Professor mayit Moser Dr Moser is one of
the founding directors of the Cav
Institute for systems neuroscience and
of the Norwegian Institute of Science
and Technology in tonim Norway May Britt
received her PhD in neurophysiology at
the University of
Oslo uh under the supervision of per
Anderson uh she went on to a short
post-doctoral position in the lab of
Richard Morris of Morris waterm Fame uh
before beginning her appointment at the
Norwegian Institute of Science and
Technology since then Dr Moser has
co-led with her husband Edvard Moser a
remarkable research team that has in the
last decade produced some of the most
astounding advances in our understanding
of the brain circuitry underlying
spatial navigation one of these one of
the most remarkable of these was their
publication in 2005 uh of a paper
describing the discovery of grid cells
in the medial entor rinal cortex since
then they have gone
on to um describe the properties of the
neurons as well as their interactions
with cortical and hippocampal circuits
maybrit has received numerous awards for
her beautiful research but one of these
I would particularly like to uh focus on
uh because it really emphasizes her um
something about her that is really
remarkable which is her commitment to
The Human Side of science uh she
recently won from a Norwegian um uh
business Society the award for best
female boss for her consistent focus on
teamwork and uh community
spirit so um I hope you'll join me today
in welcoming maybert Moser uh for this
lecture so thank you very much Michael
for these nice words and I have to say I
was very proud to be elected as the
business female of in Tron time so that
was funny that you got to know and uh
thank you for you and the organizers for
inviting me thank you for Sharp
for supporting this lecture it's a great
great honor to be one of the speakers in
this lecture series and I have enjoyed
the day here with all this fantastic
science that is going on and I know that
I just saw this tiny tiny bit of it so I
would love to spend weeks here just to
learn what you all are doing and it was
also so fantastic to meet one the
postto so what I I would like to tell
you about today is uh grid cells places
and neural maps for
space and I want to
start just with the vision of all of us
in
Neuroscience what do we really want to
understand the Neuroscience we want to
understand how the brain is generated
mental
functions but that's a bit almost a a a
rude idea to have because the brain is
so complicated and can we understand
ourselves and we know that all these
neurons all these billions of neurons
they connect to so many other billions
of neurons so how can we ever understand
this complicated thing that we have
between our
ears
we can start by looking into humans
humans with
lesions and I'm going to play one of my
favorite movies here with a
man who was a
musician he worked in England for
BBC and he got an hus infection to his
brain eating part of the medial temporal
lobe
and what happened to him is that he lost
his memory he couldn't find his way and
when when he's talking here in this
movie that we will see in in a tiny bit
you will understand what a disaster it
is for us humans if we don't have this
part of the
brain
one man is consigned to live entirely
within the present with terrible
[Music]
consequences Clive wearing has the worst
case of Amnesia ever
[Music]
known 20 years ago he lost his memory
and now his wife Deborah is the only
person he
recognizes
the second
[Music]
[Applause]
wife C really only has less than 30
seconds memory and to say about it just
like death no thoughts of any kind no
dreams no difference between day and
night no sight no sound no taste no tou
no smell te like death no difference
between day and night no thoughts
nothing as far as I'm concerned the
doctors have been totally incompetent
I've never seen a doctor the whole time
look
[Music]
who
Wonder musical kiss I'm dizzy I don't
know which part of the room I'm studying
in Can we dance
so his wife was just in the kitchen to
get a cup of to coffee or tea and he saw
her and thought he hadn't seen her for
ages because he had no memory and this
is uh his notes in his diary here and it
says here at 8:12 in the
morning I'm awake but then he is
Disturbed and then he's Crossing it out
and then he's coming back at 9:24 a.m.
now I'm awake but I wasn't because I
wasn't conscious so it's really a
devasting problem that cing has he
reminds us about another person that we
have learned about long time ago h m who
also had Aion in the medial temporal
lobe and he got that
from his surgeon who wanted to relieve
him from epileptic seizures and he
removed the hippoc compus and part of
the medial and uh temporal L and like C
Clive
bearing after this uh surgery hm could
not recognize Hospital stuff he couldn't
learn new faces new names he couldn't
learn new things he couldn't remember
new episodes and he couldn't find his
way to the bathroom so his spatial
navigation system was also not
functioning and for the next 55 years
each time he met a friend each time he
ate the meal each time he walked in the
woods it was like it was for the first
time so that made
neuroscientists interested in this
structure the hippoc compus this is the
human hippoc compus dissected out and
you see why it got its name hippoc
compus is the seahorse
so then people want to to explore these
areas in the brain and the hpoc compus
of this cute rat here we can in in this
area we can record electrical
potential while this rat is just happily
running
around and we can then try to find out
what behavior correlates is activating
this uh this cell
and this is exactly what jonke did when
he in the 70s discovered the play cell
and I'm going to show a video for you
where we can listen to one single cell
in the hippoc compus of this animal that
is happily eating chocolate and you also
have to see that the rock is just
concentrated on finding
chocolate let's see if it can get the
mve it
too so here you listen to this one cell
in the hippoc compus and the red dots
that's the action potential of this
cell and you see the rat is doing
exactly the same thing when he's here
and when he's there but the cell knows
exactly when the animal is up there and
when it's down here because here it's
silent
and here we see the path of the animal
the white trays and the red dots that's
the activity of this cell and uh this is
the rate map and warm colors is the peak
rate and the peak rate for this specific
cell is six Herz and Matt sitting here
Matt Wilson he showed together with
Bruce mcnorton that if you can record
close to 100 such cells at the same time
time you can predict where the animal is
with 1 cm Precision if you record for
say 10 minutes that's quite amazing so
this suggested then for J Keef that
these cells they are uh elements of the
brain's map of
space and they even suggested that a
cognitive
map so when my husband and me Edward uh
moved to tram just after we came back
from General ke's
lab we we had this Burning question in
mind how are these spatial signals in
the hippoc compus
generated and we wanted then to explore
uh the hippocampus circuit so this is
the hippocampus underneath the
cortex and you know that the information
here is going from theal cortex to the
dent to C A3 and up to C1 back to
subiculum and back to Ando ctis again so
what we thought was that if we blocked
this road going up to C1 we can then ask
whether there's still play cells in
C1 and surprisingly when we recorded in
such a preparation so this is a crystal
Violet stain of uh coronal section and
you see the C3 is gone and we could then
record in C1 the places look
beautiful so that led us to think maybe
uh the the C1 is receiving information
upstream and that led us to put our
electrodes into this pink area which is
the aninal cortex so this is the back of
the brain you see that cellum is removed
and this part here is the medial andrino
cortex and we wanted to Rec in the
dorsal part of the midle andrino cortex
because that is the area that is
projecting to the dorsal hippoc compus
where Jon o Keef discovered the
plays and if we then uh Play the movie
again with the rat running around doing
like the rat with the hpoc comple
recordings just chasing chocolate we can
ask how does this cell react when the
animal is uh running around in the
environment so now there is no sound
there are just white dots where the
animal no where the cell is firing and
you see that the rat is running running
running but already now you see that
it's quite messy the
activity so maybe there is not good
spatial uh um information in the aninal
cortex but if you have a happy animal
you get good coverage of the
environment and if we have this good
coverage that we will have in a while we
just speed up the movie a bit you start
to see a pattern so it looks like
there's one hippoc comple Playfield here
another hippoc comple place field here
and so on but this is in terino cortex
and it's one cell and you see that the
activity is distributed throughout this
environment not only is it distributed
this activity
but there's a certain pattern in this
activity what kind of pattern can we fit
in
here a hexagon yeah and the smallest
unit of a hexagon is
an equilateral
triangle and you can just tile your
bathroom or your kitchen floor whatever
you want with these beautiful
cells and what is even more amazing in
is that this is from a brain and the
brain cell has to know when the animal
is here then it is allowed to Fire and
this cell has to know that it shouldn't
fire here even though the rat is dancing
around that's quite
amazing so it has to get information
both about speed and direction in order
to do this calculation
and we suggested them that this is a
universal 2D
ruler so that you can measure how far
you go in an
environment what is even more amazing is
that if you think about where this grid
cell is located in the brain and I just
borrowed this diagram from Felman and
Fess the visual
hierarchy starting with the retina and I
here here further and further up in the
hierarchy hippoc compus and aninal
cortex is at the top of this hierarchy
so now you see that the grid pattern
happens to be or the grid cell happens
to be in a place that this pattern has
to be generated by the brain itself it's
not a response to directly response to
sensoric input like you would find down
here and that make us being a bit Brave
when it comes to our vision the grip
cell may put us in on the track of
neural codes for mental functions
because it's so far up in the cortical
hierarchy and when we found these cells
you could say this is a Norwegian
phenomenon and we were so pleased when
people started to report these cells in
New York in London in France everywhere
so it wasn't only a Norwegian phenomena
but not even least here we ourselves
found these cell in the mouth the first
ones were the in the
at and other groups in Israel for
example nakum lon's Group found them in
the bat and the B is quite distant uh
phenetically from a
mouse and uh Elizabeth Buffalo's group
they found uh grid cells in in in the
monkey and isak fed and Kahana reported
grid cells in
humans so this is quite relevant for us
to try to understand these types of
cells so the next question question I
have here is do we have one grid map
that is just filling up the whole ento
CeX or could it be several and how can
we find out we can find out by looking
at the grid structure and the grid
structure can vary along several
Dimensions one dimension is where are
the fields located in the
environment
so that's the
ph and the size of the grid the scale of
the grid might
vary and the orientation so if you think
about the grid cell as a mathematical
paper that you can just bring with you
everywhere you know that you can rotate
it it can have a different scale and and
and so
on and what we've shown earlier in
published work is that the pH uh is just
random uh so if you record close by
cells they will have a different faces
the
scale is progress progressing from the
dorsal to the ventral andal cortex that
I will show in a bit and uh at the end
of the lecture I'm going to tell you
some really fun new data that are so
fresh that I almost got them on the
plane on the way here guarding
orientation but let's look at uh the
scale first of these grid cells so this
is a um A
sagittal uh section of a rat brain you
see the beautiful hippoc compus here you
have the ortex here Layer Two here with
that we can record this grid cells there
are also grid cells in other layers and
you see that at the top here uh close to
the entral Border you have a small grid
fields and a small distance between the
fields so it's a good resolution map and
then you move down to the vent part and
I'm going to comment on this video it's
just
running uh and here at the bottom you
can have very very big grid fields and
that's why I show this movie here
because we are also how big can these
fields be and then we didn't get a
soccer field uh to test these animals on
in Norway even though they have been
really kind to us but what we could do
was to put up an 18 M linear track in
the lab and then let the rat Gallop I
can show you again how beautiful
Galloping theat is and he's not
Slim
and he's just Galloping to get his
chocolate at the end of the 18 M linear
track and by by letting the animals
running on this linear track we could
measure how big this grid Fields could
be and uh they were at least 3
m do you want to see him fishing the
chocolate
again he's a beautiful rat
good
style okay there's the
chocolate so what we what we ask then is
is it so that the scale is increasing
like we put these dots on a balloon and
we blow up gradually or are there
different Maps so that these scales jump
in
size and to address that question we
needed to record many many grid cells
from one rat and we had typically 200
close to 200 cells from each
rat and this figure just shows an
example from rat 142 57s I think this
might be Omega all the rats they have
names because they are
pits and the grid size here is on the Y
AIS and on the x-axis we have the
position in the aninal cortex so it's
more and more ventral and what I want
you to to to focus on here you start as
I said with a small grid scale here and
then it's jumping to the next level and
to the next level and to the next Next
Level and we used the K means clustering
procedure to show that these clusters
were distinct and we call these clusters
different modules or different
maps and what is so interesting is do
you see a pattern who is yeah this is
MIT you all are good in mathematics of
course why should I ask but do you
see the secret number that is between
these different
steps how can we find this secret number
we can take module one or
map the bigger of the modules and divide
by the smaller ones and these are the
different values for each rat and the
cross is the average and what you see
here is that the ratio between the the
the scales of the grids is
constant so it's
increasing in a
geometric
function so the grid scale is increasing
by 1 14 two each time it's moving from
one map to the next and that's the
square root of
two and of course the set point in in in
in each rat is is different but if you
have enough cells and rats then you can
find this and then there are some people
doing computer models like U uh
Alexander matis and John Herz and all
these no Andreas Herz and these people
and they have made a models showing that
a geometric progression may be optimal
to represent the
environment uh with the highest uh
resolution with a minimum number of
cells so what we asked then is it so
that these maps are or modules are
independent so how can we find out we
can manipulate the environment and ask
if these maps are reacting differently
to the different uh manipulations and it
was a very very simple experiment so we
recorded grid cells in this box that is
quite big 1.5
M and then just squeezing in one
wall so that is one M here and 1.5 M
here and then uh putting pulling out the
wall again and then we asked how do the
grid cells react to this manipulation in
the
environment here are some
examples from the same uh from the same
rat and these are the small modules and
these are the larger modules this is
before we squeeze the Box this is during
the squeezing and this is afterwards and
what you see here with the smaller
modules is that when we squeeze the box
it was like we chopped off the grid
pattern do you see that so it's these
these grid Fields here are
gone and that means that the best
correlation here if you're trying to
stretch the map afterwards is when you
don't stretch
it but here with the bigger
modules you have to stretch it the full
length in order to get a correlation
between the original map and the the the
the squeezed map so that means that
these different modules react
differently to this
manipulation
and why is that important because this
is fed into the hippoc compus and you
remember both in Clive and with hm
hippoc compus is important both for
spatial memory and for for
um for uh for for memory in general and
if you're going to generate different
memories in the hpoc compus then an
efficient way to do that is that the
grid sets are
independent and they can react
independently to the different uh
environments or inputs that you have and
when you then uh have uh when you sum up
the activity of the grid cells you can
get uh a play cell activity here I'm
going to show in a in a different figure
how this is done but at least this is a
way to separate different
memories in the hpoc compus to to to
have um the shifts in the grid
cells so the question here is how can
you go from the grid input to the hippoc
compus so that we can get a play cell
activity as a
result and that is what we remember this
is the place field this is the grid
field and how can you go from from one
to the other you can do this linear
summation as I said so if you think
about the different scale uh grid cells
here you just uh put them on top of each
other you align them then you see that
uh here it's canceling the activity out
when you do the linear summation and in
the middle it's summed up so that you
get one field like here here so this was
a model that not only our group came up
with but but but a lot of other groups
also suggested that this is a way to get
Place fields in the
hippocampus but you know that science is
more complicated than this so if you
think you have a solution to a problem
you
don't so we found later that in inter
mingled with the grid cells there are
also other types of cells one type of
cell was discovered in another structure
of the brain by Jim Rank and
T and he published these cells in 1990
and that is the head Direction cell so
if you want to do spatial navigation it
doesn't help you only to know where you
are and how far you have gone but you
also need to know the direction and you
get the direction here by this head
Direction cell so what happens here is
that when an animal is moving in an
environment when it's facing its head
towards one certain direction this cell
is firing and then it's turning off if
the uh animal is uh turning its head so
that's why it's called a head Direction
and The Polar plot shows that so
whenever the rat is moving towards
West this cell is active and when it's
moving to other directions it's it's
silent and this cell has a different
preference so that was the first cell
that coexist with the grid cells and
then in 2008 we also discovered other
type of cell that we called the Border
cells and these cells they are active
along the borders of the environment
like you see here and then you can
stretch the wall here and you see that
it's still signaling the wall you can
stretch the wall in the y direction and
it's still active along the whole wall
you can remove the walls and it's still
active because there are edges to the
environment you can give uh the r
another wall or a mirror that we gave to
Emma
here and you see that this cell is
active uh also in the insert
wall and another cell type that we just
got is the speed
cell and I told you in order to get to
to generate the grid cell activity we
need information about the speed of the
animal and this experiment was done by
Milo C uh in in our lab and uh it was
inspired by Flint how many of you have
seen Flintstone before Oh some good so
what is special about Flintstone
car do you know how he's driving like
this and that is exactly what the amelus
rat had to do emus rat had to be on this
car and the car was moved by a motor and
the rat had to run at different speeds
because the car was driving but he had
to run in order to drive it and what you
see here is that whenever the speed is
changing this cell will follow the speed
of the
car and different cells have different
preference to to different
speeds so this is a a a cell that uh is
very important for path
integration uh we
think so this leaves us with this
problem that the simple transformation
from grid cells to play cells from 2006
does not account for these new uh cell
types and also during
development it seems like the different
cell types mat at different time
times so we might also ask here maybe
the Nature has solved this by not
letting all these different types talk
to the hippocampus Maybe it is so that
it is only the grid cells that send
information to the hippoc compus and not
the head Direction cells and not the the
Border cells so how can we find out so
I'm a psychologist so then we had to in
our lab we had to to hire people who
know molecular biology so I could take
on a molecular biology
hat and what we did this is all
published was uh to use the a virus
that would then infect cells in the
hippocampus and also infect accents
coming from the ental cortex and since
these were combined with chopine we
could record them cells in the ental
cortex at the same time that we could
stimulate these with light with optic
fiber and then we could
ask if we Rec a grid cell it is in ined
if it's responding to the light if it's
a head Direction cell it's infected if
it's responding to the light and so on
and what we found was that all cell
types responded to this light and there
were lot of control experiments and S if
you want to check you can see this this
paper but the main message here is that
it isn't so simple that it's only the
grid cells that are projecting to uh to
the hippoc
compus
in
addition we have this problem with the
development as I said because if this
linear summation model would be perfect
then the grid cells would be mature
before the play cells and that is not
the case so both we and uh J wil alas
the first author showed that the play
cells are mature before the grid cells
are the grid cells are there but they're
not beauti hexagon activities so they're
not clean and not so many of them but
what is interesting is that the Border
cells are born very early on and just
after the the animal has opened its eyes
at around day 15 these beautiful uh this
is at P 17 these beautiful border cells
uh could be uh
recorded So this fits with an idea that
John Keef and and Neil Burgess and Tom
Harley and all his people in London
suggested that maybe it's possible to
use this border cell activity uh to
create Place fields in the
hippocampus and there are some problems
with that because these are just active
along the wall so that means that these
uh these uh cells in the middle would
have some um with fields in the middle
would have some problem so there's
something that we need to find out but
at least there's a possibility so the
question is then how is it with one
single place field sitting in the
hippocampus getting all this information
and then I'm just borrowing here a slide
from art con's group where he did uh uh
Optical recording of a cell in uh
V1 uh in visal cortex and he could can
also uh uh um see the activity of the
different inputs to this cell by calcium
Imaging and he stimulated the cell and
these inputs by showing the animal
different oriented uh
bars and what it could show is that
different inputs had different
preference for these different
orientations and if you think about this
as not as a a a a orientation selective
cell but as a play cell you can imagine
that these are head Direction input
border cell input grid cell input and so
on and what conet could show in his
group was that even though there's this
mix of
input the end result for the cell is
highly
selective and uh Carl swabber showed
this so these the sample here of copsis
were quite small but car wber sort of
confirmed that uh the the output is an
average of uh quite diverse inputs cars
W had around 200 copses that he could uh
uh look
at so if it's so that the hippoc compus
is receiving this mix of
input is the hippoc compus confus
us and what how can the hippoc compus
deal with its confusion is there a
selection mechanism within the hippoc
compus that can picking out information
from the border cells or from the head
Direction cells or from the grid cells
at different
times there's one
mechanism that we know about at least
one mechanism that we know about that is
a good selector for information and how
a different system can talk to each
other and that is
synchronization uh for example uh with
the gamma Rhythm or other types of brain
rhythms that can make communication
between distant areas much more
easy and you have good face relation
that is if they talk to uh to the other
structure when um both of them are
depolarized and there also a bad phase
relation
so in this way the brain can select
input because uh select inputs that
resonate with the local frequency and
sorry and that we have shown in our lab
with Laura Colin in our lab who showed
this beautiful work where she recorded
in C1 of the hippocampus and she could
then uh show them that uh uh C1 could
shift its uh frequency and would then be
synchronized to C3 at a slow gamma and
synchronized to the mle and Rhino cortex
with fast
gamma we followed up this oscillation
thinking uh when we wanted to explore
another structure also giving input to
the hpoc compus that we haven't talked
about yet and that is the lateral aninal
cortex so up to now we've been talking
about the medial anino cortex so what
does the lateral anino cortex do for the
hippoc compus at least what we know is
that the lateral Andino cortex is
receiving a lot of olfactory
input feeding then the hippoc compus
with this input and then I want to show
you a
video here do you recognize this
scene have you seen this movie I haven't
seen the movie I've just seen the scene
because I haven't had time to see but
it's about a rat in France in this
really fantastic restaurant and rat is
the chef and he's making the most
beautiful food and this scene is from
when the critics is sitting there
testing the food from the
rat and he's so unhappy and I don't like
this and blah blah blah so what you can
see here is what happens when he's
testing this food and what I want to
illustrate here is that hippocampus
stores associations between odor and
space and his hippocampus is working at
full speed as you will see in this
movie
you see he sent back to his
mom so just this taste and this odors
from this beautiful food from the
rat was
linking his memory or his
mind to something that had happened long
time
ago so
and even his emotions
change who the I demand to know oh so
he's not happy about the rat but we
ask how how can we test this in the lab
how can we test how all Factory
information is selected can we test that
in the lab do you know about the task
that you can tell us to do we have
one and this is so that the rat is told
that if he's smelling chocolate he
should go to position a if he's uh
smelling banana he should go to position
B and um our students uh or posts K and
our student
train this animal for a long time so
that they would reach an Astic level to
85% correct and I can see if this video
works so that you can see how a rat is
behaving when he's smelling this odor
sorry okay
odor
good well
done so you see his he's sent to to the
different places by just smelling
exactly like we saw in the movie with
the man who was sent to his
mom
a it's not perfect all the
time now he was smelling too short so he
was punished by not getting anything and
then he starts to explore what's wrong I
want my uh
chocolate and now he can do it
again so what we were interested in was
to understand what happens in the brain
when this animal is learning this task
and then of course we wanted to put our
electrodes in the lateral andrino cortex
and in the hippoc compus at the same
time and first we recorded the
EG I think he has proved that he can do
the task hasn't
he so we recorded the EG first as I said
in the distal C1 that is the part of C1
that is receiving input from the lateral
andrino cortex and in the lateral
andrino tics and also in the medle andr
notics to
compare and this orange part here this
is time and this is the frequency of the
EG this orange part is when the animal
is smelling the odor and it has to
sample the odor and you see that
something happens here in this frequency
between 20 to 40 Hertz and the same
thing happens in the lateral and cortex
but not in the middle and rinal
cortex so what we can ask is is it so
that there's a link between C1 and uh
lateral andal cortex are they
synchronized yes there are so if we see
the coherence between the distal C1 and
the lateral andal cortex uh on the
different EGS so then you see that it's
a high coherence in this band 20 to 40
Hertz but that is not the case between
dist one and the medial andr cortex and
this is at when the rat really knows the
task and this is just to to to sum it up
so you see between these frequencies
here it's a high coherence between these
two areas so then we might ask is this
something that is there like this or
does it develop with
learning
and it does so when we start when the
rat is quite naive on this task there's
not uh much coherence between these
structures lateral and and CTIC and the
this c one but you see that it starts to
develop and then when it come to the
asymptotic level it's just beautiful but
what if the rat is doing an error what
do you think how does it look like is
there coherent activity then can you
vote please who's voting for coherent
activity during
errors one two
three okay let's
check there is not uh much coherent
activity here during errors and to to be
fair we downsampled the number of Trials
here so that we could compare it with
the number of Trials during the errors
and uh still uh uh with correct Behavior
there's a strong coherence between these
brain areas but not during
errors so then if you record the cells
in these areas do you think that they
will also change their
activity the plays yes they
do so we see a development of order maps
so there is a place field and then
during
the learning of this odor the odor map
is put on top of the place
map and
increasing uh in firing and then uh uh
red color are those cells that will
increase the firing towards odor a and
green color are those that uh will
increase the firing towards the other
order and this is the math behind it and
again
you see that during errors this odor map
is not
expressed so what does this tell
us it tells us that the different
network oscillations May couple the
hippoc compus
temporarily with different regions of
the aninal cortex and there's a big
selection it's both the medial andan
CTIC and the lateral and all the
different information within the medle
andrino cortic that can be coupled by
these Network
oscillations coupling with different
oscillators in anal cortex may enable
play cells to listen to different inputs
during different
behaviors and the development of
coherent firing within the distal uh C1
and the lateral andal cortex May create
functional ensom just group of cells or
this odor Maps
and
uh I didn't show that but they also
modulated by this EG so that the spikes
are coming so close that you can get
heav and ltp between them so firing
together firing
together
so I could also say very briefly here
because I see I'm I'm running out of
time that uh uh it seems like there is a
development uh of uh correct Behavior
here the black
line that follows uh that is followed by
the coherence between the lateral and
cortex and the C1 and the development of
odor map in the lateral andin cortex but
C1 is a bit slower so it seems like
maybe C1 has to learn from theat lateral
andrino cortex to do this task but the
last question and that is the fresh data
that I got almost on the plane that I
will go talk about now is addressing
this question the odor map is
superimposed on the place map like
episodes like our memory we use the the
the place cell system to put our
memories on top of how are spatial Maps
kept stable in the environment because
if the the spatial maps are not kept
stable our memories are not uh stable
either
so that is what I said here to be useful
for memory navigation grid cells they
have to Anchor to the external reference
frames and then we can ask what are
these reference frames are the landmarks
are they uh the shape of the environment
how what we know is that it's true that
the grid Fields uh are stable across
trials and that was was uh shown already
in 2005 this is Tri trial one trial two
three different cells and you see that
uh the fields are located exactly the
same place and these fields can be
stable for weeks months and fleen he
lived for one year and uh I think his
cells were really really
stable another phenomena here is that if
you so in all this task where we test
the animal we have an environment where
we have a big Q card and if we have
curtains around environment so that the
animal is focusing on this Q card we can
rotate the whole environment and what
happens then is that the the the whole
map is rotating together with uh with uh
the the Q
Cod so that means means that somehow
these grid cells they have to Anchor to
landmarks in the environment and maybe C
or maybe something uh different and how
is that done what is also fascinating is
that if you check the orientation of
different grid cells in an environment
so this stripe is just showing how the
grid is oriented in environment it seems
like it's quite similar between
animals so is there an external factor
in the environment that can tell the
grid cell how to orient in the
environment
maybe so these uh uh plots here are just
uh two demonstrations from two different
rooms we call them the Galaxy
plots so so if you focus here on on on
one room here the box is 150 by
150 and what uh we've done that means
the PhD students what they have done uh
T and and
H uh they have marked the the fields
here the inner fields of the
grid with one dot and then the next
field is getting another Dot and then
this would be one grid field and then
you have all the these uh different
cells close to yeah
587 cells uh plotted on top of each
other with different
scales and what what what do you see
here regarding the
orientation so this is this is the Box
coordinates here x AIS y
AIS it looks quite stti table doesn't it
the
orientation so all of these cells they
sort of relate to this wall in the
environment do you see that so if you
have wrote it it like a clock then this
is the axis that they are relating
to
this these cells from these animals 220
cells they choose two
walls
this
wall and this
wall and what is even more strange is
that it's not perfectly aligned to the
walls there's an
offset and the offset is 7 and 1
12° so I started in mathematics I went
went into psychology and now I'm back to
mathematics and what you see here is
that it's
avoiding
zero and 15° and having a peak here at
uh 7 and A2 de and if we just move this
histogram to this side everything is at
7 and 1 12° so this is how the grid is
oriented
itself towards the walls and I was
playing with this idea
here and uh suggested uh by by
discussions of course T thought of of of
this before uh me was that
when when you have an angle if you have
the grid and it's a big triangular when
you have an angle of
30° between the grid and the wall the
other wall would also have 30
degrees if you have 15° you would have
15° H yes here but if you have 7 and A2
degree you would have a different
distance from this axis to this axis and
in this way the different grid cells
would differentiate between
these two walls and the geometry of the
environment is extremely important for
the rat when it's finding its way in an
environment and in order to test this uh
T and H did
simulations and they just simulated
cells uh with same orientation and same
uh spacing for each uh each uh
simulation but then different spacing
and different orientation um uh for for
for each map here and then they uh just
asked if if you do this simulation and
then correlate activity between this
segment close to this wall and this
segment close to this wall then we can
ask how can you get the least correlated
information when is the grid located in
the environment so that uh the grid can
distinguish between this wall and this
wall that's the
question and the
simulations showed what we uh uh saw in
the data at 7 and a half degree the
correlation is at the lowest highest at
15 and so it
goes and that is also um oh I thought I
had deleted so so so this is just to put
the simulation upside down and the the
the the recorded data
here seeing here 7 and a half has the
smallest correlation but highest
representation among the
cells and then we were so astonished by
this how is it possible so one thing is
how can the grid cell know when to be
active and when to be silent but how
could the grid cell know what is 7 and 1
12° towards one
wall crazy if you ask
me and I was just no this is this is uh
this is uh so strange and then I went
back to the already published paper and
then I almost fainted because I saw
15° and I I run to to T and Han and said
we have just published 15 degrees what
should we do we can't publish 7 and a
half and what happened then was
this just
crazy so T and H played with the grid
map of oma one of our
and it seems
like the grid Activity The Grid
cell can dissolve so that one part of
the grid cell can uh have 7 and 1 half
degrees to one wall one wall but another
part of the grid cell can map up to the
other wall and we've seen this
before and that was in an already
published study where that we call the
hapin mace study that you can reset the
map in each
Corridor so by putting up walls in the
environment the grid cell starts over
and over again so here if you go back to
this there is this diagonal so this map
is one map in the grid cell and this map
is another map that
is aligning to the different
walls
crazy okay so I just wanted to to show
here who uh did all this
work so we have a a fantastic group of
people and this year we had snow now we
don't have snow in Tron time but you see
we had snow here so of course the Edward
my husband he has been involved in in
all this work and all these Maps uh is
uh all published data I want to also say
especially men is working in tram is
involved in in much of these studies and
the mechanisms I didn't have time to
talk about how do you generate the grid
cell but that is yasar Rudi group the
modules and also this 7 and a half
degree that is this couple they have a
2-year-old daughter no three maybe and
now they're expecting
twins productive in the lab productive
everywhere and this is K who did
oscillations to together with Laura kin
who has now got a job in Texas Emilio
with the speed cells and this is uh uh
the people who found uh the the grid
together with us and Alexandro tev who
has also been collaborating with us for
a long time and um uh yeah the the
Border said St scha and and so on and um
oh oh okay I thought I lost the
funding so we got a lot of support from
from our local University Anon New Cav
Foundation has been fantastic the
Norwegian research Council uh with the
center of excellence and the European
research Council and um yeah je
foundation so we we get a lot of support
and thank you for being patient with me
I've spent too much time talking about
these data but thank you for the
attention Okay so we have time for a few
questions that was really beautiful and
I was just so curious have you looked at
the Orient
envir are
triang um I think I have that slide here
I hope I didn't delete it because you
asking for example what happens in a
circle
and these data are So Fresh So we
haven't sort of been thinking uh enough
uh but it seems like in in a Circle you
don't have this regular orientation like
you have in uh the square boxes it's
it's it's more
varied but what we are discussing now is
that maybe the Q card could help with
some of the orientation but uh we don't
know so we are exploring different
shapes of environments to address your
question
godamn it uh when you were doing exper
experiments with cerence I was just
wondering since you have an attracted
righta have you tried do doing an ex
Extinction of that trying to look at a
avoidance they seem to be having a place
firing at Borders at the wall showing
that they do that they do have obstacles
but I'm wondering if you have have
something that is not attractive
something that you don't want to
navigate navigate to would you find the
same oscillatory
coherence I don't know if you understand
my question or not yeah no so so it's
about the coherence experiment that we
did uh in in the lateral and thotics and
the coherence between lateral and
thotics and the
C1 and avoidance that I didn't
because because it's said to be in a
well TR a well trained rat right there
that to have to have to C Lev and you
won't have and I'm just curious because
on the wrong on the wrong trials it
doesn't have have that fire incoherence
right there but is there any feedback to
say to saying that this is a wrong one
and if you reinforce question if you
reinforce that if you extinguish that
and you have telling them to avoid this
instead would you have opposite effect
or not that's what I'm wondering yeah no
so so so that that's that's a wonderful
question so what what we think is that
uh uh the lateral andral cortex and the
hippoc compus need to talk to each other
in order for the rat to remember which
position to go to and if something
happens with this
communication so that there is not
coherent activity in this 20 to 40 Herz
band then there is no communication
between the lateral andal CeX and see
one that is good enough for the behavior
to be correct
so that is what we're thinking but I
agree we if if you could block the
coherence also artificially by putting
in chanine or Hine or whatever you could
and then manipulate this then you could
also ask could you sort of erase the
memory or the behavior so that he could
start to do errors Maybe by
manipulation
yeah no so so so that's also true that
uh they need the the the spatial map
intact in order to do this task because
they have to know where to go and what
is so fascinating about that is that uh
the best method for us to
remember long lists of words or numbers
or whatever is to use spatial memory of
course so there was a children program
uh on television in Norway where the the
program um leader of this program she
had to learn 20 countries 20 cities in
those countries she would also uh say if
uh how they were related to each other
the borders of these countries and she
had to learn this in 20 minutes and you
would say this is an impossible task but
it wasn't impossible because she was
taught to use her spal memory in order
to remember this so what she did was
that um uh she used the the house or or
her home and then she placed the
different memories in different rooms so
that she could have neighboring rooms
with neighboring countries and in each
room she had to have two uh two um Adas
of of of this country and and uh uh the
city so for example for tur turkey it
would be um this is in Norwegian so it
would be a
tear it's an
ox and an anchor and then it was turkey
and ankor and then she had all these uh
uh imagination for for the different
countries and then she could just do
this mental travel going from one room
to the next to just sample her me
memories and she did this task with no
errors so the spatial uh navigation
system is just perfect and it's the same
cells in the compass that are dealing
with place and
memory I have two I guess related
question one is maybe related to the
first question so um Reds probably have
not involved in environments with walls
if anything they were running out in the
open field with maybe very local
landmarks like rocks trees and things
like that so what is the angular offset
data that you just showed me with
respect to how they have evolved um
these kinds of mechanisms and the other
question is um maybe for the uh speed
cells you mentioned briefly humans now
can travel in very fast speeds probably
unprecented
unprecedented um speeds so what are the
um flexibility for these maps to scale
up are there limits like do do we you
know adjust with respect to what we
perceive like what what do you think of
those kinds of things that's really
exciting question so uh for the for the
for the last one uh we know that we can
still uh at least drive the car even
though our speeds are above speed limits
that's easy in Norway because they are
so low but uh and but but um uh I think
you're right with the plasticity because
when you
break then you don't break fast enough
because you have this speed illusion so
you have sort of learned to to be in
this very high speed so when you want to
break and go out to the gasoline station
you don't at least if if you don't think
about it then uh you think you are
driving slower than what you do and uh
regarding the environment of um the
animals um exciting question but no data
I'm sorry so but absolutely so so that
is why we are exploring all these things
to start to learn
how are these activity patterns
generated and how are they form how are
they anchored what can we learn about
this uh these uh cells because if we can
learn something of these cells we think
we can learn also something about the
brain in general we
hope CL have a question um I was just
wondering you're talking about the
importance of visual input when the the
maps are kind of being being developed
um once they're already established is
visual input important for like
retaining that information so say you
know with the um the smelling task if
you blindfolded the rat after it's done
that a few times would it still be able
to find the location um and I was also
wondering if if there's anything known
about the place in visual system where
like the projection happens um CU you
were talking about V1 so it's does it go
like is there any retinotopy or like I I
I guess I was just curious about the
visual
input so uh regard um that was many
questions so you have probably have to
help me but uh but uh there's no written
a topy in the andral cortex as far as I
know but maybe Bob knows more about that
but talking about uh odor input for
example we see that uh uh in the old
cortex even then it's uh it's not uh any
topographical organization of the old
input side I don't expect that to be in
in the anano cortex either so the the
direct sensoric link to what happens in
the aninal cortex is lost on the way so
it's more Associated and also associate
with uh different inputs so that was
that was one question and then it was
you don't even know oh my my memory is
so bad I'm sorry just about I guess how
visual input helps um like
yeah so so what is interesting with uh
with the grid cells is uh like I said
it's like a 2d metric and we think that
it's useful for path integration and
path integration you can use without
visual input so you can just close your
eyes and you can start somewhere you can
move and then you integrate the speed
and the direction and you can go back to
where you started but you need visual
input in order to to Anchor the grid we
think and that is also what I I I showed
when when uh we have this Q card in the
environment and when you rotate the
environment then we rotate the whole map
and not only the grid cells are rotated
the head Direction cells will rotate the
play cells will rotate and everything
will rotate as a full map and that is
also quite exciting because when when
people talk about these head Direction
cells they think that uh the these are
Compass cells or to the magnetic poles
but it's a
subjective head Direction system that is
plastic that you can just move
around okay I'm sure there are many more
questions um you can ask mayit um
questions at the reception that will be
outside right now and let's thank uh her
one more time for coming
[Applause]
[Music]
to